"So why Tahiti what brought you here?"
"I wanna chase adventures"
Hello who is this guy?
What's it like sailing out there all alone?
You're either sleep-deprived or seasick and after a few days there's hallucinations!
Why did you do it?
Theres a feeling I can't describe
Its just you and the infinite horizon
How would you like to sail the Hassana to California first?
What do you think?
I think 4,000 miles is insane.
I'm not going anywhere without you. Come sail with me.
Bon voyage lovers!
" Hurricane Raymond has taken an unexpected turn"
"And has been upgraded to a Category 5"
We need to make sure everything is secure.
Should we be worried?
I love you!
Get below!
Oh my God.
Richard!
It's gonna be okay!
I'm gonna take care of you.
We're thousands of miles from land, we are not in any flight paths that's like a 1,500 square mile search area.
A needle in a blue haystack.
Is anybody there?
Mayday!
My ribs are broken my leg shattered. I'm dead weight
What if we sail to Hawaii? It's about 2,000 miles shot at a moving target if you miss Hawaii..
If we miss Hawaii we die!
I can't do this.
You can do anything you put your mind to
I sailed half way around the world to find you
I'm not letting you go!